Let's take Phi to be
this vector right here.
It's a unit vector, which we can see by
computing the Euclidean norm and that's what this circle represents,
it's all of the unit vectors
having real number entries.
Let's also say Psi to be
this vector right here, which again is also a unit vector.
It's the minus state in fact, but here we're just calling it Psi.
If we compute the inner
product of these two vectors, we get one minus the square root of three over two times root two,
which happens to be approximately -1/4.
The value of this inner product is equal to the cosine of the angle
between the two vectors, which you can see here in the figure.
That's something that's
generally true for unit vectors. If we have two unit vectors and they both have real number entries,
then the inner product between them is equal to the cosine of
the angle between them.
In particular, if the inner
product is equal to zero, like in this example, where we've changed Psi to
be this state right here,
then the two vectors must
be at a 90 degree angle to one another.
This all generalizes to
vectors in any dimension, by the way, as long as the
entries are real numbers, it's not just for two dimensional vectors.
If we have complex number entries, the picture doesn't really
work anymore, but nevertheless, the inner product is every
bit as useful as we will see.
The inner product has some
very important properties and we'll take a few moments to observe some of those properties now.
First is a connection
between the inner product and the Euclidean norm.
If we take the inner product
of any vector with itself, we get the Euclidean norm squared.
So we can alternatively say that the Euclidean norm of a vector is equal to the square
root of the inner product
of that vector with itself. This isn't a coincidence, this
is a fundamental connection, and here we can see that if we didn't have
the complex conjugates in the definition of the inner product, then this formula
wouldn't be true anymore, and we wouldn't have such a useful notion
with this fundamental connection
to the Euclidean norm.
Next, the inner product
is conjugate symmetric, which means that if we swap
the order of the two arguments, then the value we get for the
inner product gets conjugated.
That's expressed by
this equation right here and is quite straightforward to see why this happens for these two expressions
for the inner product of the two vectors in the two possible orders.
The inner product is linear
in the second argument. Specifically, if we define a vector Phi to be this linear
combination of two vectors,
Phi one and Phi two, then the inner product of
any vector Psi with Phi is the same linear combination
of the two inner products,
and this follows quite
directly from the fact that matrix multiplication is linear.
And we also have that the inner
product is conjugate linear in the first argument, which you can see expressed right here.
If Psi is this linear
combination of vectors, then if we take the inner
product of Psi and Phi,
then Bra Psi becomes this vector that we see right here where we take the complex
conjugate of beta one and beta two,
and so this is the result and that's what's meant
by conjugate linearity.
And the last property of the inner product that I wanna mention is
the incredibly useful Cauchy-Schwarz inequality.
For any two vectors, Psi and Phi, the absolute value of the inner product can never be larger than the
product of the Euclidean norms
of the two vectors. And moreover, the only way that the two
sides of the inequality can be equal is if the two
vectors are linearly dependent,
which means that one of them is equal to some scaler times the other.
This is in fact one of the
most widely used inequality in all of mathematics and
we use it over and over when we're talking about
quantum information,
so it's very good to know about.
Next, we'll talk about the
notions of orthogonality and orthonormality which are
connected with inner products
and specifically, with
inner products of vectors being equal to zero.
To be precise, if we have
two vectors, Psi and Phi, we say that they're orthogonal
if their inner product
is equal to zero. And the way that we can think
about orthogonal vectors intuitively is that they're
at right angles to each other,
or alternatively, that they're
perpendicular to one another.
People sometimes use the term orthogonal to refer to things that have
nothing to do with each other, like saying that one issue
is orthogonal to another,
but that's obviously pretty informal and not really meaningful
in a mathematical sense, but the connection is clear if you think about orthogonal
vectors as pointing
not in opposite directions, but in completely different directions like north versus west for instance.
If we have a set of vectors, we say that the set is an orthogonal set if any two distinct vectors
chosen from that set
are necessarily orthogonal to one another, which we can express
as you see right here,